brian qu'est ce que tu aimerais qui se
passe pour tes parents maintenant ou
déjà déjà j'aurais mais j'aurais mais
déjà au qui sortent pas de chez eux
aujourd'hui ah oui bayal qui ne sortent
pas pardo qui sortent pas du
commissariat qui soit directement emmené
en prison sont ou là aujourd'hui ils
sont à leur domicile et reçoivent des
visites donc seul puisque de leurs
parents ont été placés voilà ces sommes
mais pas seul puisque le leur famille
côté de montperreux leur voix leur
rendre visite comme si comme si rien ne
s'était passé nation comme s'ils étaient
de leur côté
j'aurais voulu on mes parents voilà
comme chez kiki qui ne sortent pas de
gardes à vue qui sont amenés directement
en prison pour ce qu'ils ont fait
aujourd'hui sont ils sont jugés au mois
de janvier le 24 le 24 précise aimerait
une épreuve aussi pour vous tous ceux se
ses ce procès il a forcément mais ce qui
nous choque le plus tous autant que
notre tous autant que la clautre c'est
que leur peine maximum prévue pour eux
est de deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30
mille euros damende incroyable sans
savoir que les 30000 euros damende ne
seront pas condamnés ou seront condamnés
mais pas payer car les parents ne soient
pas redevables note aucun argent sur 28
aux enfants victimes de et aujourd'hui
on ne veut pas d'argent aujourd'hui on
veut voir mes parents souffrir comme
vous vous avez souffert ça sera pas à ce
point même si aujourd'hui demain les
condamne à quinze et vingt ans j'ai vécu
trés en torture peut-être pas j'ai
peut-être pas été l'enfant qui a pris le
plus de coups plus d' insulte mais voir
ses frères et soeurs
victime aussi de tout ça ça a été pour
moi de la torture encore ces dernières
semaines
promo de deux ans de prison on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui le ban en quelques
mois le juge ne va pas les condamne à
cette peine on va leur mettre qu'on veut
leur lettre six mois de sursis on va
leur mettre des travaux d'été généraux
dans une crèche pour qu'ils savent
s'occuper des enfants
aujourd'hui le le procureur nous parle
pas de en gros de torture il dit que la
maison ils ont en horreur c'est
s'aggraver 1 je ne pense pas que que ce
monsieur je n'espère pas pour lui qu'il
ait vécu le quart de ce qu'on a vécu je
ne pense pas que ce monsieur aurait le
courage d'accepter tout les coûts que
mes petits frères et moi on a reçu je
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui ce monsieur
aurait le courage d'être là aujourd'hui
témoigner contre ses parents toute
l'horreur qu'ils ont fait blanche 2 je
me demande à je me suis de devoir c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui amis tous tous
mes frères et moi même à terre il nous
arrive on nous a remis un coup on avait
déjà pris avec ses déclarations il ne
sent bien congrès aujourd'hui je veux
qu'ils sachent que caen va pas qu'on va
se battre qu'on va pas lâcher et que on
donnera tout pour que mes frères et
soeurs ressemble amour qui sont jamais
eu la sécurité je demande à ce jour deux
procureurs de ne jamais et jamais
remettre les enfants dans dans l'est
lebron mes parents n'est pas un métier
mais jamais leur donner l'occasion ça me
de croiser le regard
après tout ce qu'ils auront fait de
condamner à hauteur de ce qu'ils nous
ont fait simplement et pas à deux ans de
prison maximum ou